para empezar con este vídeo primero que
todo vamos a dar rápidamente mencionar
que nuestra baraja no tiene comodines y
puedes hacer los mismos problemas con
comodines solo que quizás al final
tengas un poco de resultados diferentes
pero fuera de eso primero pensemos en
cuántas cartas
hemos estado cubriendo en un juego
estándar por lo que tenemos cuatro palos
y estos palos son picas o espadas
diamantes tréboles y corazones
y luego cada uno de estos palos tendrán
13 diferentes tipos de cartas lo cual es
llamado a veces como el rango entonces
cada palo tiene 13 cartas diferentes
pues tenemos los as 2 3 4 5 6 7 hasta el
10 y luego tenemos la j la reina el rey
y estás en total forman 13 cartas
entonces puedes tener para cada palo
puedes tener cualquiera de estas
cualquiera de estas cartas por lo que
puedes tener una jota un diamante un
picasso una jota de corazones o quizás
una jota y un picas etcétera entonces si
multiplicas estas dos cosas puedes tomar
cada palo por sus 13 cartas de cada palo
en total nos dan 52 cartas y otra forma
en cómo puedes hacer esto es que puedes
pensar que tenemos 13 rangos o 13 tipos
de cartas
y por cada palo son cuatro palos
diferentes cada carta o cada una de
estas cartas puede venir de diferente
palo y nos vuelve a dar 52 pero bueno
ahora pensemos en cuál sería la
probabilidad de que me saliera una jota
entonces de tomar aleatoriamente una
carta de la baraja vamos a pensar cuál
es la probabilidad de que me salga una
jota entonces podríamos tomar cualquiera
de estas 52 cartas por lo que son las 52
posibilidades y tenemos 4 palos en los
cuales va a haber en cada palo una jota
entonces esto sería una probabilidad de
452 a 2 y como ambos son divisibles
entre 4 nos quedaría un treceavo ahora
vamos a pensar en cuál será la
probabilidad de bueno digamos que
volvemos a tomar dicha carta de jota que
nos salió y la ponemos dentro de nuestra
baraja por lo que volvemos a tener 52
cartas así que cuál es la probabilidad
de obtener un corazón
una vez más tenemos las 52 cartas
entonces son 52 posibles
igualmente probables eventos donde
estamos tratando de tomar una carta de
corazón entonces esencialmente 13 de
ellas tendrán nuestros corazones de
interés para cada uno de lo que nosotros
demandamos entonces tienen 13 tipos por
lo que son 13 corazones en dicha baraja
las 13 cartas están en la baraja y
también hay 13 espadas en la baraja 13
reyes o 13 as entonces son 13 de 52 que
podrían resultar ser corazones lo que
sería divisible entre 13 y nos va a dar
de respuesta un cuarto ahora hagamos
algo que es un poco más interesante o
quizás se te haga un poco más obvio cuál
es la probabilidad de que al tomar una
carta que sea una jota y corazones una
jota y corazones bien si estás
ligeramente familiarizado con las cartas
pues es solamente una
que tiene a ambos una jota y corazones
es literalmente una jota de corazones
entonces estamos diciendo que cuál es la
probabilidad de que exactamente tome la
carta de jota de corazones y bien solo
hay un evento que cumple con dicha
condición que cumple con nuestro
criterio entonces aquí sería uno de 52
posibles e igualmente probables eventos
que ocurran ahora sí hagamos algo un
poco más interesante cuál es la
probabilidad y quizás en esta parte
quieras hacer una pequeña pausa y pensar
un poco más la pregunta antes de que yo
dé la respuesta y la pregunta es cuál es
la probabilidad de que bueno teniendo
otra vez una baraja de 52 cartas la
baraja más aleatoriamente y tomamos una
carta entonces cuál es la probabilidad
de que dicha carta que tome salga una
jota o en un corazón entonces esto
podría ser una jota de corazones o
podría ser una jota de diamantes
o de picas pero también podrá ser una
reina de corazones o un 2 de corazones
entonces cuál es la probabilidad de esto
y nosotros sabemos que otra vez tenemos
52 posibilidades pero cuántas
posibilidades de estas cumplen con
nuestro criterio y para entender un poco
más estoy dibujando un diagrama de ven y
suena como algo de fantasía pero no es
fantasioso en realidad estamos aquí
plasmando lo que estoy preguntando así
que vamos a imaginar que vamos a decir
que estar aquí son las 52 posibilidades
los 52 posibles resultados y que este
pequeño círculo de aquí va a ser la
probabilidad de que salga una j este
pequeño resultado de aquí sería
estrictamente un treceavo o 452 a vos de
estar aquí y la dibuje algo así porque
es la probabilidad que está
representando entonces son 452 a vos que
al dividir los nos da él
un 13 agua ahora cuál es la probabilidad
de obtener corazones y bueno podemos
dibujar otro pequeño círculo aquí que lo
represente donde son 13 de estos son del
lastre de las 52 cartas 13 pueden
representar nuestros corazones entonces
esta parte de nuestro círculo se va a
interceptar un poco con nuestro círculo
verde este es el número de corazones y
esta parte de arriba la voy a modificar
para que sea un poco más entendible y
vamos a decir entonces que este va a ser
el número de jotas
y el círculo magenta que puse abajo va a
ser el número de corazones y por
supuesto esta intersección aquí donde se
traslapan es el número total de jotas
que estamos interceptando pero que
también son corazones entonces es la
jota de corazones es ambos en este
círculo verde y en este círculo magenta
entonces tenemos esto de aquí y lo
pondré de color amarillo y entonces es
el número de jotas y corazones así que
cuál es la probabilidad de tener una
jota o un corazón y si lo piensas la
probabilidad va a ser el número de
eventos que van a cumplir con dicha
condición sobre todos los eventos pero
tiene que cumplir con nuestra condición
y como ya sabemos hay un total de 52
eventos igualmente probables pero
cuántos estos 52 las cumplen y va a ser
el número bueno
observa que el círculo verde de aquí
el círculo de la probabilidad de obtener
una j y el círculo magenta nos dice que
es el número de obtener un corazón
entonces sumando las probabilidades del
círculo verde y el círculo magenta
estarías quizás teniendo algún doble
conteo porque si sumas solamente 4 52
ambos más 1352 a vos que estás diciendo
dices que tienes 4 jotas y que tienes 13
corazones pero en ambos de estos estamos
contando la jota de corazones estaríamos
poniendo la jota de corazones y en este
primero y luego en este otro así que
estás diciendo que tienes como dos jotas
de corazones inclusive aunque sólo haya
una carta de estas entonces hay que
restar la parte de la intersección o
restar ese pedazo de probabilidad que
tiene a ambos
así que restaría uno y otra forma de
pensar lo es figurando t el área total
de aquí el área total déjame hacer una
cercanía entonces estoy generalizando la
así que tenemos un círculo como éste
y luego otro círculo como este y
tendrías que tomar el área de este
círculo y luego sumarle el área de este
otro círculo pero cuando haces eso
puedes ver que cuando sumas las dos
áreas estás contando esta área dos veces
así que en ese orden tú solo cuentas un
área así que basta con restar el área de
intersección por lo que si esta área
está y esta otra es b y la intersección
s el área combinada sería a más b menos
donde se enciman entonces es lo que
hacemos aquí estamos contando todas las
gotas y eso incluye ya la jota de
corazones y todos los corazones que ya
incluye a la jota de corazones así que
podemos tener la jota de corazones dos
veces pero la tenemos que restar para
completar esto por lo que sería 4 13
menos 1 lo cual nos da 1652 a vos y en
ambos casos son divisibles entre 4 por
lo que nos va a quedar
413 a vos y entonces esta es la
probabilidad de sacar una jota o un
corazón listo